so long as people are coming here to
live peacefully and work peacefully I
think the government should have to show
to us why they shouldn't be here
I am Nikolas be with reason today we're
talking with Shikha Dalmia she writes
about immigration at The Reason
Foundation where she's a senior analyst
and she is also a columnist at the week
Shikha thanks for talking about having
meaning Trump is elected immigration
huge huge element of his appeal how bad
is his immigration plan for America in
living memory we can't think of another
candidate who's been quite this bad and
Trump's awfulness extends far and wide
but on the one thing that he's been
consistently offered as immigration they
talk about the various stages of his
immigration policy as he's at least
proposed and you know first during the
campaign and now more recently after I
mean so there aren't just two phases to
his policy right there three before
Trump ran he was actually pretty good on
immigration I mean one of his criticisms
of Romney was that he was too harsh with
Latinos and that cost him the election
so it came something as a surprise when
he started talking about Mexicans and
such harsh terms criminals and all of
that
bringing disease disease which is you
know vintage nativist stuff as you know
I mean this is what 1920s 1930s you know
was this magazine and the judge I mean
this is what they slam against
immigrants was so he went from being you
know we should be welcoming to
immigrants in particularly labor the
laboring class right now he's against
all Mexicans and then what's the third
stage so now he has Jeff Sessions
Republican senator from Alabama on his
team who's always been bad on
immigration there is no form of
immigration he actually likes he wants
to cut back on every whether it's family
whether it's employment whether it's
low-skilled whether it's high-skilled
and you know the one Sacro sankt piece
of immigration that all Republicans to
date have supported is high-skilled
immigration the high-skilled immigrants
good low-skilled immigrants bad that's
been kind of like a perennial Republican
theme he wants to change that he
actually recently proposed even
scrapping the h-1b program which has
been the big source of high-skilled
immigrants
to this country so Trump is a little bit
vague on that on everything else he is
you know there are many elements to his
immigration plan there is the wall which
he was going to have Mexico pay for
which he has backed off on but the wall
still persists you know he wanted a
deportation task force to hunt down 11
million immigrants plus 4 million
Americans who were related to them and
throw them all of it out of the country
he's saying now he'll focus on the 3
million criminal aliens to begin with he
is very hostile to so-called sanctuary
cities these are cities that actually
are obeying the Constitution because
they basically won't fit the federal
government to produce a warrant before
they will detain illegal immigrants for
any period of time or ask inquire about
or inquire status because and the idea
behind sanctuary cities is that local
police won't be able to solve crimes
crimes or local issues and if immigrants
legal or illegal are afraid to talk to
the police because they're going to get
sent over to immigration that's right
what's behind the anti immigration push
in Trump if you look at the polls they
are the exact reverse of what they were
20 years ago 20 years ago about 60% of
the American public wanted less
immigration and about 40 or 30% wanted
more after 20 years of immigrant bashing
by various Republican conservative talk
show hosts it's actually flipped now 60%
want more immigration and 30% want less
immigration and yet you know so it's a
bit of a mystery how Trump has gotten
where he has but I think there is a very
powerful contingent of alt-right white
nationalist people who are allowed they
come out and vote and he managed to rope
them in now I would actually think that
he himself is necessarily a nativist I
mean you know his whole look he's
married to a woman to a nimah current
woman who was once illegal to two out of
three or immigrants two or three are
immigrants and but the current one
Melania there's pretty good evidence
that she worked illegally in this
country at some attaboy at some point so
he's not an ideological nativist but
he's a political entrepreneur
men what explains the fact that in the
early exit polls he said he actually did
better among Latinos than Mitt Romney
did I think one reason is because of
Florida in Florida the Latino vote was
about 31% for him in all of the other
swing states it was actually he got less
than 17% of the hospital spanic vote and
I think he got more in Florida was
because of the Cuban element what is the
best possible alternative to a kind of
restriction esteem aggression policy
which also not only keeps people from
coming in but then rounds up and kicks
out people who are here what's what's
the best that we can hope for over the
next few years you know my hope for
Trump is this if I were advising him
what I would say to him is okay you know
you want to secure America's borders I
mean that's his central premise right
let's just tweak the way you were going
to do it you cannot really secure the
border so long as the incentive to come
to this country illegally is what it is
there is a great deal of demand for
low-skilled workers what we need where
the Mexico is a guest worker program so
let's begin a guest worker program let's
give people legal avenues to come to
this country which means let's stanch
the future flow of illegals and once we
have once we see how much that actually
cuts down on illegals then let's see
whether you need to build your wall and
how many people you need to throw out of
the country
so don't give up on your promise but at
least reprioritize it and start with
something that's likely to work rather
than something that's not likely to work
and so that's if you're advising Trump
if you could write immigration policy
you know on a clean sheet of paper what
would it be I am in favor of very
liberal immigration policies I think
anyone who comes to this country if they
have a job or if they are here to join
an American it is because some American
wants them here so so long as people are
coming here to live peacefully and work
peacefully I think the government should
have to show to us
they shouldn't be here right now the
presumption is the other way round
Americans have to show to the government
why they should bring somebody here I
think that presumption should be should
be switched so that doesn't mean that
you let in terrorists it doesn't mean
you let in people who have a public
health problem you let in people the
government does proper scrutiny but you
don't have a blanket ban on people
coming into the country which is the
policy that we effectively have right
now well thank you we'll leave it there
we've been talking with Shikha Dalmia
she's a senior fellow at Reason
Foundation and she is also a columnist
of the week Shikha thanks for talking to
us
thanks for having me for reason I'm Nick
Gillespie
you